donc en 2013, ma famille et moi avons atterri en
France et oui, nous sommes venus jouer de
manière très très légale au cas où certains d'entre vous se
demanderaient, il y a 10 ans, nous ne
connaissions pas du tout français et pour être honnête
quand je suis arrivé pour la première fois  ici,
je me sentais comme un poisson de l'eau et
j'étais submergé par des émotions contradictoires
euh
[Musique] [
Musique]
alors quel était le fruit
Je suis toujours un ami Je suis toujours un ami
plus je me perds un ami, plus je
perds ma culture un ami  aussi mon
identité
mais aujourd'hui 10 ans après il s'est
avéré que c'était tout le contraire je suis toujours
moi
toujours syrien acier Europe et je suis
déjà humain il y a palestinien mais je
suis aussi frais et je suis européen le
gagnant bien sûr
[Musique]
par exemple à  Ici, j'avais l'habitude
de manger des pommes de terre écrasées, puis quand je rentrais à
la maison, j'avais juste ce capitaine
[Musique]
qu'il avait l'habitude d'abord d'être mangé parce qu'elle
disait
en ligne
[Musique] euh
peut-être que c'est parce que je me sens chez moi chaque fois que
je visite notre pays, même  même si ce
n'est pas mon propre pays par exemple le
mois dernier j'étais en Jordanie et j'avais l'impression que
c'était la Syrie même si ce n'était pas la Syrie
étranger
euh
je me moque toujours de mon colocataire qui est
ici d'ailleurs
très
européen Français Allemand Australien
Occidental
Association
qui est mon plat préféré les égyptiens très savoureux
et c'est ce que j'entends par frais à la maison
un frais à l'école chez les syriens à la maison
cependant j'ai découvert beaucoup beaucoup de nouvelles
choses ici en France un exemple
parce que
[Musique]
ne sont pas mariés  comment peut-on naître comment
quelqu'un peut-il avoir des enfants si ses
parents ne sont pas mariés parce qu'avant cela, je
ne lui ai jamais reçu d'
éducation sexuelle et j'ai toujours
pensé que pour avoir des enfants,
il suffit d'être étiqueté comme marié
sans sexualité  en partie qu'ici en
France j'ai appris qu'on peut avoir un
enfant sans être marié et c'est
merveilleux non
donc j'ai réussi à embrasser ces deux
cultures comme je disais et je crois que
c'est aussi grâce à mes parents pourtant
très religieux j'ai  la chance d'avoir
des parents très ouverts d'esprit qui
aiment vraiment ce mélange entre français et
syrien donc
j'ai été élevé dans un environnement favorable
au multiculturalisme ou tout simplement au
culturalisme par exemple quand je dis à mes
parents que je ne traîne qu'avec
des filles qu'ils n'aiment pas'  ça ne les
dérange même pas en fait mais si je dis ça à mes
articles qui sont en Syrie ils
le verront comme un légume tu as plus de bénéfices à court terme
mais malgré tout ça et au delà de tous
ces exemples que
tu connais
et pour  mon expérience Insider au sein de
leur monde, puis en dehors de votre
expérience lorsque j'y retourne et que je leur rends visite. J'ai
rencontré beaucoup de gens
extrêmement résilients et incroyablement
généreux malgré le fait de vivre dans des
circonstances très difficiles et d'étudier l'informatique
[Musique]
parce que l'arabe est une langue tellement merveilleuse.
langue, je veux dire, la plupart d'entre vous apprennent l'arabe
et même si vous avez du mal à l'apprendre,
cela reste une très belle langue
étrangère
[Musique]
après mon propre voyage, j'ai appris
qu'accepter la diversité peut être renforcé
et cela peut vous aider à construire la vôtre
personnalité ou plutôt je devrais dire
personnalités
[Musique] étrangère étrangère
[Musique]